and right now i think i like black
clover more than my hero academia
and i'm going on and i didn't i didn't
think you know
did i just say something blasphemous i
don't know how can a man be so brave
you have made the black the black clover
fandom extremely happy now
yeah you've given them validation
recognition
here's your validation everyone but not
because i feel like with black clover
it's just
so much fun it's just fun it's just this
is the
this is the pure shonen fun i was
looking for and with my hero academia i
feel like
it's trying to go for greatness it's
it's like it's trying to build
a long con it's going for long con it's
trying to build up so many so many great
points and great characters
but it's just doing a lot of things that
is just not keeping my interest as well
like what the [ __ ] okay what the [ __ ]
was that last arc in my hero academia
season four as well
with the villain who i can't even
remember the british guy basically
whole quirk is that like he what is it
like he drinks tea
yeah i i really actually i don't
actually think that's his quirk but all
he does is drink tea oh he can make
things into
he's basically hisoka he makes things
into rubber oh
wow yeah but then he drinks tea so
that's like
like that's also his big thing is that
he's like really picky about tea
right and i'm like is this how he like
envisions british people yeah yeah
because yes that's actually true
like the entire arc just felt like a
filler arc that wasn't actually filler
and i know people are going to be mad at
me because yeah they are looking forward
to the comments
they enjoyed the school festival and
everything but i was just not invested
enough in the side character just to
really give a [ __ ] about the school
festival
and the villain was just [ __ ] weak
source as [ __ ] so i don't give a [ __ ]
about that
so it that entire arc was just complete
i'm gonna forget that one when season
five is yeah i
i i wonder is is my hurricane trying to
go for like a
10-year run here or do you think it's
going to be like i feel
yeah i feel with just how successful it
is i'm sure people are showing and jump
well because i think the people are
showing and jumping they want a reward
replacement they want no not not so much
one piece replacement but they want
something that will line up with one
piece for a while because
we've currently had you know
demonstration standard hike you just put
it
in is one piece gonna end anytime soon
uh well
no oda said that it'll end in the next
five years but who the [ __ ]
in one piece he is though that's pretty
soon it's one pc's that's really soon
but
the mug has been going for like 25 years
i'm wondering as a fan who
has been watching my hero from the start
right how did like
do they really expect someone to be into
a show for 10 years
yes yeah of course i've been into one
piece for over 10 years yeah
i've been into one piece for as long as
i've read it like when one piece ends
i think my mom gave up like being
interested in me after like eight you
know what i mean
like she [ __ ] birthed me like
i'm kidding when one piece i'm gonna cry
like nobody oh no i'm going to [ __ ]
cry when one piece
because that's like a huge part of my
life that's just right
yeah it's it's just it's just like it's
just like your head
i guess i was i guess i did watch like
game of thrones for like 10 years
like it's eight seasons right but they
took like two years in the last oh yeah
that's true
i mean think about it that was the worst
ending think about the amount of people
who [ __ ] cried when harry potter
ended
and that show had been going off well
not sure but like that book series has
been going off like [ __ ]
knows how long true true i guess i guess
i underestimate i guess when you say
be interested in this for 10 years it
sounds hard but then in real life it's
very much not like that it's not like
every day you're like i'm caring i'm
caring
yeah yeah yeah you go on twitter there's
actually some people who are like yeah i
[ __ ]
love one piece every year but that's
their only personality right
your tinder profile i like one piece
yeah it's like oh
we're we're meant to be you know it's it
was so weird
like seeing even something like naruto
and seeing the characters grow up
and like kind of like growing up with
characters
i mean like i sh i [ __ ] on borrowto and
everything but
some of those first few episodes where
you see naruto as a dad and you see
sasuke's that and you're like
man well the same thing happened with
like when the [ __ ] avatar the last
airbender ended right and then the first
episode
the first episode of coral was like oh
my god qatar is old now but then after
the first episode was like all right i
don't [ __ ] care
i like cora i thought i thought coral
was kind of made
you [ __ ] love that word i loved all
four seasons were the four seasons
of cora no i think it was three i loved
all of it i don't know i might
people had their complaints but i was
like okay okay because i i never grew up
on
avatar neither we neither yeah i only
just recently watched it like the last
couple years yeah me too
avatar's [ __ ] amazing i actually
still haven't seen it okay it's [ __ ]
i i i completely understand the hype now
because it's
[ __ ] great but then i watched core
and i was like it just doesn't
this doesn't hit this doesn't hit
different it's
like a great anime uh kind of feel but
also has that comfort of a
saturday morning yeah yeah it's really
like in a sweet spot the jokes
are like very campy i don't think i've
ever heard you talk about something as
endearing as you just talked about
it really like takes you it's like it's
like how you felt
i imagine when i say like imagine when
you were trading yu-gi-oh cards with
your friends yeah
that level of like oh man yeah that was
fun wasn't it i can totally understand
why people are just as interested today
as they were back then